hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my Suicide Squad two video you
heard that right
Warner Brothers has already started
working on Suicide Squad too even though
the first movie hasn't even come out yet
there are a couple big reasons why
Studios do stuff like that they know
Suicide Squad is going to make a lot of
money but they don't know how much and
that could change when the movie is
released it's going to take them at
least two years to make it so it's
probably going to happen is is you're
going to see a Suicide Squad movie in
the fall of 2018 now in case you guys
weren't sure when all the DC movies are
coming out they already have several on
the schedule here's a breakdown of that
real quick starting after the first
Suicide Squad movie so we have that
coming out this fall then there's Wonder
Woman June 2017 Justice League part 1
November 2017 later that year then the
year after that the flash movies coming
out in March 2018
then the Aquaman movie July 2018 that
summer then the next year in 2019 Shazam
is coming in April just asleep part 2 is
coming that June 2019 then the year
after that in 2020 cyborg is coming in
April and the Green Lantern Corps movie
is coming June 2020 so what will
probably happen is DC will release three
films in 2018 they'll have the flash in
March
they'll have Aquaman in July and then
they'll probably release Suicide Squad
around the same time they're releasing
it this year sometime between August at
the end of the summer in the fall they
could push it to is late as November
there really isn't a Marvel film that's
going to be released in the fall of 2018
so there's no real big competition the
other really big reason why they
probably want to start working on a
sequel now is because they need to
schedule all the actors so they don't
get booked doing other projects now I'm
sure when all the actors signed on to do
this first Suicide Squad film their
contracts had options for sequels but
that might not include all the actors DC
doesn't have the same type of contracts
that Marvel makes people sign Marvel
makes people sign a standard six picture
deal unless it's a special one-off
performance like Robert Redford and
Winter Soldier Robert Redford isn't
going to do six Marvel films so while
the big DC players like ben affleck
henry cavill gal gadot they all signed
multi film contracts those aren't nearly
as restrictive as Marvel's so a lot of
times if it can take too long to get a
movie going an actor will get busy with
another project and they wouldn't be
able to film the sequel movie it would
cause huge problems so the earlier
studios can lock
schedules down the better David Ayer
does have another project that he's
working on he would still direct Suicide
Squad to but they need somebody else to
write the movie and if they're going to
get a sequel out by 2018 they need to
start shooting in 2017 meaning they have
to have a script before that so they
just have to get started right now but I
can see some of you in the background
raising your hands what about all the
Batman solo films what about the Man of
Steel sequels you didn't mention those
on all those dates
none of those movies have official dates
yet so what I would expect is is that
they just crammed them in and you'll see
three movies a year three DC movies a
year starting after Justice League which
sounds about right
Marvel is going to be doing the exact
same thing so that's like six comic book
movies a year starting around 2018 not
even including any Star Wars films you
kind of include Star Wars in that bunch
too the next really big question is what
would they do for the story like what is
the best Suicide Squad story they could
do for the sequel well the problem is is
that we don't know what the first movie
is all about in the sequel will just
flow naturally from whatever ends up
happening but whatever's going on I'm
guessing that the Joker's relationship
with Harley Quinn will be another
central part of the series rather than
do like a Harley Quinn spin-off or a
Joker spin-off movie you'll just have a
through-line of those two characters
embedded throughout the series but
standard operating procedure for a
sequel to a movie with a bunch of
characters is that you just take one of
the underserved characters from the
first film who was really interesting
and double down on them enchantress is a
really good example of that they've been
selling her as being a big part of the
film but what if she only ends up being
in a little bit of it she ends up being
this amazing character that you only see
a little bit of will you use the sequel
to tell the story that she didn't get to
tell in the first movie you kill off one
or two of the minor characters bringing
a new one to freshen things up to change
the tone of the film just a little bit
in my great hope is that they would go
after someone from the Justice League
franchise like Suicide Squad versus
Batman or if Deathstroke is a really
small part of the Suicide Squad film it
be Suicide Squad versus Deathstroke for
the sequel I'd say I'd want them to do
Judas contract because that's one of the
best Deathstroke stories of all time but
that's really a Teen Titans story so
they would save that for the cyborg film
or whatever Teen Titans project they're
going to try and do in the movies the
new 52 Suicide Squad stories really
aren't that great but that's when Harley
Quinn became a big part of the team so
I'd rather they just stick with the tone
of Jim Australia stories even if they
want a mix-and-match character
here's a couple of story recommendations
though especially if you want to read
old-school Suicide Squad
there's the Phoenix gambit Batman has to
help put together a new Suicide Squad
team after the old team is disbanded
Amanda Waller's thrown in prison so he
has to work with her who's a terrible
person to put together the shadow team
there's against the wall that's really
like an Amanda Waller versus Batman
story like I said it'd be really awesome
to have the Suicide Squad go after one
of the big Justice League characters
there's a really awesome story that
they're probably never going to get to
do called Apocalypse Now where the
Suicide Squad goes to apocalypse and
fights the minions of Darkseid
even though thanks enchantress we know
that magic exists so there will be
really crazy stuff which is getting to
Darkseid territory but I feel like
that's something you have to work up to
think about how long it's going to take
for the Avengers from the start of phase
1 that first Iron Man film so the time
they're actually throwing punches with
Thanos in infinity war it's almost like
a 10-year jump for Marvel to go from
zero to Thanos so it's going to take DC
a little while to go from zero to
Darkseid there is a really awesome
Deadshot origin story just called
Deadshot beginnings they can totally do
a version of that but you will probably
see flashbacks for all the characters in
Suicide Squad
you'll learn how they got to where they
are it's just the win you look at it all
on paper most of the story is about
Harley Quinn and Joker so let me know in
the comments without really knowing
exactly what's going to be happening
during the first Suicide Squad movie
aside aside from them going up against
Joker what do you want them to do in the
sequel like which characters do you want
them to double down on and which other
characters would you want to see them
bring into the team I would love to see
King shark and if the Suicide Squad is
going to be the most outlandish crazy
franchise DC has like Deadpool is - the
x-men universe as Suicide Squad is - the
DC Universe you have to crank the knobs
to 11 for the sequel so what's gonna
happen is there's a new episode of
legends of tomorrow tonight I was going
to do an arrow bonus video but because
there's a new episode of legends I'll do
that first I will do an arrow bonus
video tomorrow about the person in the
grave they're supposedly leaked pictures
of the set it's really not what people
think it is but I'll totally explain to
my video tomorrow so a legends video
posting tonight be sure to subscribe to
get that in the DC giveaway is still
going on it's just a $20 Amazon gift
card I am so excited for Suicide Squad
you guys have no idea if you really love
Deadpool Suicide Squad flows a lot from
that energy but what you guys wait for
my legends video to post
you can click here for all my Suicide
Squad videos and you can click here to
learn all about the Captain America
Civil War teams thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight